l'accélération boulard c'était le 3
avril 2021 la première titularisation en
équipe de france d'emilie bout leurs
jeunes rugbywoman yvelinoise de 21 ans
une première sélection face au pays de
galles puis une seconde face aux
irlandaises ses débuts sous le maillot
bleu lors du tournoi des six nations
2021 de très bons souvenirs pour sa
famille du côté de la celle les bordes
aller et là ça part allez allez petit
coup de pied du pied droit
quand on l'a vu s'aligner avec ses
copines prendre la position et la
marseillaise
on a eu la chair de poule en tout cas
pour moi et une grosse grosse
fierté de voir un de ses enfants avec le
maillot de l'équipe de france nous a une
grosse fierté de l'avoir d'avoir la ce
niveau là en si peu de temps pour ses
premières sélections emilie boulard a
inscrit deux essais en trois matches à
21 ans emilie boulard vie dans la maison
familiale avec ses frères et soeurs une
famille de sportifs avec mes frères et
soeurs ont des global mantoue sportif
donc faire du sport ensemble même au
collège et au lycée toujours toujours
faire beaucoup de sport et j'ai toujours
aimé ça escalade à partir du collège
pendant cinq ans du coup en club plus à
l'ice unss je fais pas mal de
compétitions j'ai été championne de
france en 2013 et ensuite du coup je
passe au rugby à partir de là de la
première en unss dans mon lycée agricole
après la pratique avec l'association
sportive du lycée emilie bull a rejoint
le club de chilly-mazarin en 2017
c'est à ce moment là que sa carrière de
rugbyman commence mal club du chili
mazars ça représente tout parce que
c'est mon seul club où j'ai joué a déjà
en seniors avec ce club essonnien emilie
boulard joue au niveau élite du rugby
féminin elle s'entraîne trois fois par
semaine apprend très rapidement
illustration parfaite de sa progression
fulgurante au bout d'un an elle intègre
l'équipe de france à 7 développement à
marcoussis
j'ai fait une tournée en première
tournée en australie nouvelle zélande
par trois semaines je savais pas faire
de seven j'avais un an et demi
d'expérience niveau rugby pareil très
une expérience qui m'a vraiment fort
j'ai donc j'ai dû apprendre vraiment
très vite et ensuite ça s'est continuée
les stages avec le france développement
ensuite les moins de 20 ans suit le
léger haut de la légion universitaire et
le 15 elle a gravi les échelons d'une
manière exponentielle qui a un peu
surpris tout le monde et
notre avantage pour le club de chez guy
donc donc voila c'était assez
spectaculaire ses prochains objectifs
pour cette jeune rugbywoman participer à
la coupe du monde de rugby féminin et
aux jeux olympiques de paris en 2024